I mean everybody had head lice bhaiyya
so that's like a constant game I'm here
if you read head lice no no yeah I think
that's more of like a regional thing we
had like worms oh you did oh did if
somebody got worms dude you would take
him outside and burn them no you never
had like worms that would crawl out of
your butt and stuff Oh sand and [__] no
whoa dude we're about to go go in deep
yeah man tell me about this dude there's
somebody let me tell you somebody have
worms come out there but boss dude
they're not allowed back at church no I
thought that was pretty common for his
kids like go play in the sandbox and
[__] extremely on avid words or
whatever I remember like I maybe this is
a Asian thing but we my parents would
remedy it by [__] pouring vinegar up
my ass oh really yeah
dang bro I was like I thought everyone
went through this [__] uh-uh
I don't even know what the hell dude I
think that's how I mean that's frickin
very wormed bro that's a rare
vinaigrette you guys are making over
there right what else would they put it
in there anything else no I was just I
just I would just like yeah we have
vinegar that's it dude how are they do
it one of them like hold your legs open
or like my mom would be like all right
you know like you know when your kid and
they help you wipe your ass and [__] you
just get in that position right yeah
[__] booty in the air and then they just
pour a cup of vinegar in my pocket
yeah well it sounds like some kind of
rapper stuff dude this only something
it's like an initiation for a gang or
something yeah they sound like something
you would see on some old uh you know
some Lil Wayne [__] no that was one of
them something lusher or kelly does to
people this seems like how are Kelly
makes salad dressing you know what's
[__] up too I probably could have just
went to the doctor and got like a pill
or something and dewormed myself so they
would just pour it in and that would
kill him yeah I mean what are the worms
right I mean I would assume I don't know
man I was like in elementary school I
like first or second grade or something
but did you think about just sitting
around having worms just like being
inside of your body I mean you're
basically a bait shop at that yeah you
know what I'm bleep me out those I
remember I had an itchy ass butt and I
kept telling my pair
like what's going on ma'am I plug it
buckles been itching for ages and
they're like wow yeah making my making
me the G my see everything wrap my
crotch and people say it's you but all
that stuff in the grandma crotch yeah
there's all the ingles it just makes me
nervous yeah yeah I keep my butthole
pretty clean I feel like overall you
know I think there was a couple years
while I wasn't really caring about it
yeah but as an adult I've really you
know I shine up my shell shop no how did
you how did you deal with the headlights
what was that like Oh everybody had it I
mean you would give it to your friend
you [__] sneak up and give it to a
girl you like so you could bring her
that shampoo a couple days later well
you you would flake it on them like you
would go just sneak up behind him and
just be near him long enough
cuz bro they had some rare strands wrong
they had african-american head lice at
all types basic white dude head lice
damn bro the african-american a jump
across the [__] room on the year yeah
they do a layup mother a licen I'm like
score oh nine you know whom we'll be
jumping over each other when I'm sitting
in chairs when I'm ordering a pizza
while they're in the air all kind of
stuff but yeah head lice was popular
while I was from what other games dude
they had this big nude they had this big
dude named Wayne Wayne he was named
Wayne two times first a middle name
because his parents couldn't decide if
he wanted to name it for his first name
or his middle name until they [__]
got in a fight about it and then they
both get out of mainway know out of
anger home like oh you're not gonna
[__] let me name him Wayne then I'm
gonna [__] name him Wayne and the
other ones like oh you ain't gonna
[__] let me name him Wayne then I'm
naming him Wayne anyway Wayne yeah
that's hilarious
whether both the green like it's already
Wayne yeah but they were disagree on how
it's spelled or like no okay you know
you've had to agree to disagree this was
disagree to disagree and [__] now
they got a double wedding oh man they
got Wayne squared and ironically
horrible at math dude this dude was on
this dude was severely uneducated and he
was in school - who's probably remember
him being 40 or maybe even 50 years old
and probably in elementary school
eighth or ninth grade and that's it it
lets you stay in dude because I remember
his hair started falling out
at some point people started getting
scared because people thought he got bit
by something that's why his hair was
falling out but it was because of
adulthood you know he'd man he'd gone on
deep into adulthood anyway but the thing
was yeah people got lice by us what else
do people get man well thanks for
watching that video right there that was
a beautiful little segment I think
but of course I'm partisan to myself but
you can move on to another video right
now you could check on this video or on
this video that's two different options
and you can also subscribe to the
channel check on a new video subscribe
to the channel check subscribe subscribe